okay so the topic of this video is going
to be some of the characteristics of the
lipids and then eventually saturated
versus unsaturated fatty acids
all right so just a question depending
how do organisms store energy ponder
that and we're going to move on
but we're going to talk about lipids
today and again lipids are a type of
organic molecules along with proteins
and carbohydrates and nucleic acids so
that means they're they're molecules
that are really built around carbon
all right so when it comes to lipids
we're really talking about you know the
fats the oils the waxes you know like
you know beeswax you know the wax that
makes up Honeycombs uh butter would be
an example uh the cooking oils that
you're familiar with you know lipids one
of the more defining features is that
they're insoluble in water that just
means they don't mix so here's a layer
of vegetable oil floating on top of
water and even if we were to get a spoon
and stir this up uh the two would never
mix and eventually the vegetable oil
would just separate out on top like you
see in the picture
so when it comes to lipids let's talk
about the two building blocks the two
parts there's a head that we call the
glycerol molecule and then attached to
the glycerol dangling down are some
Tails called fatty acids so here's a
very generic drawing of a lipid but a
more realistic drawing might look might
look a little bit like this this is a
lipid and there's the glycerol head and
there's fatty acid one fatty acid two
fatty acid three
now if we look at the molecular
structure of the glycerol there's the
glycerol right there and here's a fatty
acid notice uh in red there's two h's
and an O well that's going to be water
in a moment in in a in a dehydration
synthesis reaction water is removed and
the fatty acid bonded to the to the
glycerol let's do that two more times
here's another fatty acid and then water
is removed and the second fatty acid
bonded to the glycerol and here's a
third fatty acid and water is removed
and notice how we now have one gigantic
molecule made from the glycerol head and
then in this case One Two Three fatty
acid Tails attached
and so here's a triglyceride again and
if we look at the function of
triglycerides this is really an energy
storage molecule there's energy stored
in the bonds of the atoms that make up a
triglyceride
and so if we look at one of the fatty
acids here you know flashing in red are
the bonds in between the carbons and the
carbons and the carbons and in that in
those bonds there our energy or is
energy that the cell can use for its
needs
a secondary function of lipids is
insulation you know if you're a whale or
you're an elephant seal and you're
swimming through you know the chilly
ocean waters having a thick layer of
blubber helps to absorb or helps to
sorry trap heat uh to you know to keep
you warm and it's a great form of
insulation for organisms that live in
cold environments
and another function for lipids is in
the structure of our cells you know
here's a cell right here if we zoom on
into the cell membrane
and when we zoom into the cell membrane
here we see the basic units of the cell
membrane a phospholipid so you might
remember from learning about cells that
the phospholipids and the cell membrane
the phospholipids are the foundation of
the cell membrane
and the cell membrane regulates a what
can enter and exit within the cell
also there's another lipid in the cell
membrane embedded within the cell
membrane are cholesterol molecules these
are very important in adding flexibility
to the cell membrane so I know lipids
often have a negative
stereotype to them because we associate
lipids with fats but here's two examples
of lipids that are the very Foundation
of our cells
so let's start to focus now on the
difference between saturated and
unsaturated fatty acids here is the
backbone of a saturated fatty acid
flashing in red you'll notice a single
bond in between every carbon and carbon
there's a single bond this is
characteristic of a saturated fatty acid
and the reason it's called saturated
because when I add the rest of the atoms
the carbons are filled with hydrogens
and the word saturated just as a fancy
word that means to be filled with so
saturated fatty acids are these chains
of carbons that are filled with
hydrogens
and so notice how the chain is basically
in a straight line the chain is
therefore very densely compacted and
these saturated fatty acids fatty acids
tend to be solid at room temperature
hence butter be in solid at room
temperature and lard being solid at room
temperature saturated fatty acids tend
to be most of the animal fats and so
again butter is made from cow's milk and
lard is made from Pig fats now there are
exceptions to this but that's just a
general characteristic that saturated
fatty acids tend to be animal fats
but if we look at unsaturated fatty
acids notice in between a couple you can
see it blinking red in between a couple
of the carbons is a what looks like an
equal sign or a Double Dash This is
called a double bond that double bond
creates a little crooked kink in the
chain of carbons
and the reason it's called an
unsaturated fat is because there's just
a few less hydrogens than normal if you
look right here
are hydrogens needed in those two gaps
right there do I need to draw in two
more hydrogens I hope you see the answer
is no
carbon can only Bond four times right
now all those carbons have four bonds
attached to them there's no space for
two more hydrogens
and so this Kink the double bond right
there causes the a kink in the chain and
that causes the molecule to be less
dense and liquidy at room temperature
hence vegetable oil and another example
would be some things like corn oil and
peanut oil and avocado oil again oils
that come from plants and also fish fats
tend to be unsaturated fatty acids
well if we look at you know digesting
and breaking down lipids well that
involves a hydrolysis reaction and so
Hydro implies water and lysis means to
break down and in a hydrolysis reaction
with the additional water a lipid can be
broken down and so here's a water
molecule and enzymes along with water
will break off one of the fatty acids
let's do that again here's another water
molecule that breaks off the middle
fatty acid let's do that one more time
here's another water molecule breaks off
the third fatty acid so notice the lipid
has been broken down into the glycerol
which is the part on top and then the
Three fatty acids which are the three on
the bottom
and so let's talk about a medical
condition known as arterial sclerosis so
normally here's an artery with red blood
cells traveling through them
and so normally blood will flow freely
however Arthur artherosclerosis is a
medical condition where there's a
buildup of cholesterol and and and
plaque that builds up in the arteries
and you can see it can cause blockages
and ultimately this can have some
negative side effects like reduced
circulation blood clots high blood
pressure and this can be attributed to
you know a a diet with you know high
amounts of cholesterol or a high amounts
of lipids
when you get older you might have to you
know check your cholesterol levels and
so the red level high green level
desirable and the picture on the bottom
again just sums up arterial sclerosis
the top picture shows a normal artery
wide open so blood can flow freely the
bottom picture shows the plaque and how
the artery is kind of partially closed
and so these are a little some of the
characteristics of lipids here
and so here's a little practice quiz for
you pause the video try to answer these
questions if you're in my biology class
I'm happy to check your answers thanks
for watching